recognizing that video production
facilities moving image assets producer
talents video editing tools and
archiving and preservation expertise and
sites are are in so many disparate
locations it might be interesting to
think of like a collaborative you some
kind of yeah that's a collaboration
model and recently I went to see NFL
films and this is the most amazing
facility around imagine if one of these
existed for education you can sorry you
can turn that off but um the production
facilities for video he it's kind of a
one-stop shop you can do extraordinary
things with their stages you can convert
a 16-millimeter film and other formats
the post-production is all their other
creative services etc and I just think I
just imagine if they were some kind of
distributive education video studio
unforgettable images raw emotion epic
struggles I mean that's pretty much my
past year at Columbia it's it's a I can
see I can I can just see that's kind of
the you know educational experience and
maybe there is a way to to kind of
create some kind of distributed studio
because production facilities are
everywhere and all this expertise is
there it might be possible to link
across institutions beyond universities
maybe including public broadcaster's and
museums and
also with companies like Google juste
Microsoft Apple and Amazon and others so
that's the only point I wanted to make